every few years a school district is
celebrated for some eye-catching numbers
it is held up as a national model and
then later the numbers are unmasked as
deceptive in the early 80s
Atlanta's test scores showed remarkable
games the district secret sauce easier
tests in the 90s Houston's test gains
were labeled a Texas miracle a 2000 Ram
study family scores were misleading and
inflated in the mid 2000 she caii was
hailed as a model for fixing America's
schools turns out that the impressive
passage rates were fueled by lowered
standards by then Atlanta was being
celebrated again and then district
leaders went to jail for cooking test
scores I could list many more the big
problem everybody leaps to imitate the
miracle at the moment which distracts
from the hard work of actually improving
schools
be wary of models which are a melange of
quick fixes and charismatic leadership
so the next time you're told the
district X has it all figured out look
twice do you think test scores are a
reliable measure of how well school
districts are doing let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI